vont nous rejoindre
notre hors du jour ayant été
considérablement modifié ces derniers
jours on a plusieurs de nos collègues
qui nous ont fait part de leur regret de
ne pouvoir assister à notre réunion ce
matin moi aussi de mondé avait prié de
les excuser ce que je m'empresse de
faire devant vous nous avons le plaisir
de recevoir ce matin Philippe coulonjon
pour une audition consacrée à la
conscience écologique de nos
compatriotes je précise tout de suite
que ceux qui ne peuvent être présents
dans notre salle de réunion peuvent
suivre à distance nos travaux car cette
audition est captée et diffusée en
direct par Public Sénat et les
différents réseaux sociaux afin d'entrer
dans le vif du sujet avant par mon
entrée dans le vif du sujet rappelez que
notre délégation la prospective d'une
institution originale dans le paysage
parlementaire et qu'il n'y a pas
d'équivalent ni à l'Assemblée nationale
ni dans la plupart des parlements
étrangers notre mission est en effet
d'examiner les problématiques complexes
sur sur le temps long de décrypter les
grandes tendances dans les domaines
économiques et sociaux ou
environnementaux à travers les auditions
que nous menons nous abordons des enjeux
fondamentaux aujourd'hui c'est celui du
regard de la société sur ce sujet au
combien essentiel au combien important
de la transition écologique vous avez en
effet Monsieur Coulon tout récemment
consacré un ouvrage à la conversion
écologique des Français vous êtes agrégé
de sciences sociales docteur en
sociologie directeur de recherche au
CNRS et au centre de recherche sur les
inégalités sociales
de Sciences Po vous travaillez notamment
sur la sociologie des pratiques
culturelles les liens entre la
stratification sociale et les modes de
vie ainsi que les ressorts sociaux de
cette conversion écologique ce matin
vous allez nous éclairer sur les
contradictions et clivages comme
l'indique le sous-titre de votre livre
la société française face aux problèmes
majeurs de la transition écologique les
événements de ce week-end à
Sainte-Souline en sont une illustration
sans doute assez extrême mais néanmoins
emblématique des conflits qui pourraient
s'accroître dans les années à venir
autour des différents aspects de la
transition écologique et nous venons de
rendre avec la délégation nous avons
d'ailleurs eu des rapporteurs Cécile ku
Kerman un rapport sur l'avenir de l'eau
qui a pu aborder ces sujets tous les
acteurs de l'économie sont désormais
impactés il s'agisse de l'agriculture de
l'énergie de l'industrie du tourisme et
bien d'autres secteurs encore la
population c'est
aussi qu'elle devra subir et s'adapter à
des épisodes climatiques de plus en plus
nombreux de plus en plus violents que ce
soit la sécheresse que ce soit canicule
les inondations les tempêtes comment
tout cela est perçu par nos concitoyens
comment adapter nos pratiques et nos
modes de vie que ce soit à nos
consommations nos déplacements notamment
quels sont les secteurs de la société
sur lesquels nous pourrons nous adapter
quels sont les leviers que l'on pourra
activer pour que cette transition soit
acceptable par l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens
mesurer mesurez-vous des différences
selon les territoires c'est aussi un des
sujets que nous aimons à traiter dans
dans les travaux de notre délégation
parce que c'est pour nous un critère
vous le comprendrez qui intéresse tout
particulièrement notre institution le
Sénat voilà quelques premières questions
pour introduire votre propos liminaire
je ne doute pas qu'il en suscitera
d'autres et je vous cède sans plus
tarder la parole en vous remerciant de
votre présence ce matin
pour le mettre en diaporama
oui même côté merci beaucoup de
parfait merci oui donc merci de me
donner la parole et de me donner
l'occasion de présenter ce travail qui
est un travail collectif qui a été
réalisé collaboration avec mes collègues
Yoann de Moly qui émet de conférence à
l'UVSQ Mael ginsburger qui finit une
tête de doctorat sur ma direction et
puis il vautev qui est chercheur aussi
au CNRS à l'ENSAE
deux mots peut-être sur le point de
départ de de cet ouvrage et qui feront
écho je pense à la présentation que vous
venez de de faire
je pense que cet ouvrage et nous
n'étions pas les uns et les autres enfin
en tout cas pas moi mes collègues un peu
plus que moi mais je n'étais pas
un spécialiste des questions
environnementales avant de me lancer
dans dans ce travail qui qui remonte à
plusieurs années maintenant enfin le
début de ce traversant plusieurs années
je pense que ce qui nous a attiré vers
cette question c'était le l'impression
et qui ce qui me semble-t-il se confirme
de plus en plus que la question
environnement fondamental
et de plus en plus au cœur je dirais de
la conflictualité sociale dans dans la
société contemporaine et ça je pense que
c'est une question
qui a une importance politique non
négligeable c'est à dire que
effectivement un certain nombre de de
conflits sociaux de clivages sociaux de
de
de rapport de rapport de force etc entre
les différents partenaires sociaux dans
une société comme la nôtre sont
peut-être en train de se reconfigurer
autour de ces questions
environnementales au départ de de ce de
ce travail
on avait en tête le fait que pendant
très longtemps le conflit social en
France comme dans beaucoup de sociétés
occidentales c'est nouée autour des
questions de partage de la valeur un de
partage de la production
il y avait un ouvrage célèbre de
sociologue et d'économiste français de
la fin des années 60 qui s'appelait le
partage des bénéfices bon au fond le
partage des bénéfices longtemps été le
l'aliment central je dirais du débat
social et politique bon est-ce que nous
serions pas en train de basculer dans
une autre
ère ou au fond un des éléments centraux
de de
[Musique]
du conflit social va devenir non pas la
question du partage des bénéfices de la
croissance économique mais le partage du
fardeau de ces externes de ces
externalités donc au fond c'était un peu
ça la question de départ et on a voulu
essayer de montrer à quel point
effectivement ces questions
environnementales
étaient des questions éminemment
politiques au sens très large du terme
c'est à dire qu'elles impliquent des
choix qui mettent des choix politiques
qui mettent en conflit des intérêts
potentiellement contradictoires et donc
c'est c'est un petit peu ça notre point
de départ alors c'est un travail qui
essentiellement comme je l'indique ici à
l'écran sur une enquête qui a été
réalisée il y a un petit moment déjà on
aimerait d'ailleurs pouvoir la répliquer
dans les mois qui viennent parce que je
pense que beaucoup de choses se sont
passées depuis 2017
qui a été réalisé dans le cadre d'un
panel sur Internet qui a un panel qui
est mené en collaboration avec Sciences
Po et l'Inde notamment
qui a un panel d'environ 3000 personnes
à qui sont posées mensuellement des des
questions sur un certain nombre de de
sujets alors je rentre pas dans le
détail de ce panel mais bon c'est c'est
un outil qui est relativement
intéressant parce qu'il permet de il
permet d'aborder en population générale
des questions qui sont rarement abordées
par les organismes de statistiques
publics de type Insee parce que il y a
des des freins à poser un certain nombre
de de questions notamment sur les
opinions politiques etc bon bref ce qui
nous a intéressé dans
ce travail
ça a été de de
d'interroger à la fois
les représentations les opinions les
attitudes à l'égard de l'environnement
et aussi les pratiques notamment toutes
les pratiques de consommation aussi mais
aussi les pratiques de déplacement bref
tous les éléments du mode de vie qui ont
potentiellement un impact
environnemental ce qui nous a intéressé
c'est effectivement l'articulation
potentiellement problématique entre les
deux c'est-à-dire le fait qu'il y a pas
nécessairement de convergence il peut y
en avoir mais il y a pas nécessairement
de convergence automatique entre le
degré de confiance des enjeux le degré
de de
oui de de
préoccupations environnementale et
la mise en accord des pratiques dans le
domaine de la consommation de des
déplacements de des façons de se loger
de se nourrir etc
alors du côté des attitudes on
sait risquer dans cette enquête à
utiliser un outil qui a été un peu
critiqué mais qui finalement
relativement bien validé à l'échelle
internationale qu'un outil qui vient de
la psychologie sociale qu'est-ce qu'on
appelle la NEP
new
environnemental scale bon qui est un
outil
assez classique de psychométrie qui
consiste à essayer de de mesurer des
échelles d'attitude à partir d'une d'une
batterie de de de questions ce qu'on ce
qu'on a mis en évidence et je rentre pas
dans dans le détail c'est qu'au fond en
tout cas dans le cas de la population
française cette échelle d'attitude à
l'égard de de la de l'environnement
cette échelle de conscience
environnementale elle était en fait pas
unique et en réalité on pouvait
distinguer deux dimensions qui sont en
fait assez différentes donc je rentre
pas dans le détail des vitesses mais
selon les les degrés de les degrés de
d'acquiescement aux différentes
propositions qui sont proposées dans la
batterie de questions en utilisant des
outils statistiques méthodes d'analyse
factorale etc encore une fois j'entre
pas dans les détails on peut montrer
qu'il y a clairement deux dimensions
sous-jacentes de variables latente comme
disent les psychologues
qu'on pourrait pour l'une
repérer comme une échelle d'inquiétude
environnementale et pour l'autre une
échelle de défiance envers le progrès au
fond la conscience environnementale elle
se définit elle semble se définir un peu
par ces par ces deux échelles selon que
les les individus manifestent une plus
ou moins grande inquiétude à l'égard des
des des des
questions environnementales c'est tout
ce qui apparaît en grisé dans la dans la
colonne
IE et puis
une deuxième dimension qui est le je
dirais le rapport au progrès technique
avec d'un côté des individus qui ont une
très forte confiance dans la capacité du
progrès technique à
surmonter les les difficultés liées à
l'environnement et puis à l'inverse ceux
qui au contraire doutent fortement de la
capacité du progrès technique à apporter
des solutions à ces questionnements donc
en fait on peut au fond déjà répartir la
population par rapport à ces à ces deux
échelles et ce qui est ce qui ce qui
apparaît assez clairement en termes de
différenciation sociale c'est qu'au fond
la question de l'inquiétude
environnementale c'est quelque chose
d'assez socialement consensuel et au
fond ça varie assez peu selon les
caractéristiques d'âge de diplôme de
revenus etc c'est pas du tout le cas de
la défiance envers le progrès au fond le
positionnement sur cette échelle le
rapport au progrès technique et la
confiance en proie technique il est il
est très lié par contre facteur sociaux
pour vite particulier c'est très lié au
niveau d'éducation
plus les gens sont diplômés plus ils
sont sceptiques à l'égard de de la
capacité de surmonter les défis
environnementaux uniquement
par le progrès technique bon alors la
deuxième chose qui nous a intéressé
c'est là que le panel ellipse c'est là
que le palais le panel ellipse était
était pour nous un outil intéressant
c'est que c'est un panel dans lequel
sont posées
mensuellement donc tout un tas
d'enquêtes et notamment des enquêtes sur
les attitudes politiques et ils nous
étaient possibles en apparion les
données des différentes enquêtes et bien
de regarder un petit peu comment se
positionner les individus en fonction
des orientations politiques et là aussi
on voit un petit peu la même chose on a
en haut en pointillés large
l'échelle d'inquiétude environnementales
et en bas en pointillés fin la défiance
envers le progrès on voit que l'échelle
d'inquiétude environnementale elle est
relativement peu liée au positionnement
politique alors qui est mesurait à
partir d'une échelle d'automposition
droite-gauche en revanche c'est pas le
cas de la question de la défiance envers
le progrès où on voit clairement un
gradient droit de gauche
un gradient droit de gauche en gros plus
on se déplace de la droite
traditionnelle vers la gauche plus la
défiance envers le progrès est forte
avec une spécificité forte qui nous a
beaucoup intéressé qu'on a retrouvé à
beaucoup
d'égard avec une spécificité forte des
personnes qui se qui s'auto positionne
plutôt à l'extrême droite que eux on va
retrouver plutôt assez haut aussi sur
cette échelle aussi bien sur l'échelle
d'inquiétude environnementale que sur
l'échelle de défiance
envers le progrès
alors la deuxième opération qu'on a
menée dans dans cette enquête c'est
qu'on a donc posé un certain nombre de
questions aux
enquêter sur leurs habitudes dans
différents domaines de pratiques dans
différents domaines de leur styles de
vie
leurs habitudes de consommation
alimentaire quel type de produits vous
consommez est-ce que vous consommez des
produits issus de l'agriculture de
l'agriculture bio est-ce que vous prêtez
attention à la provenance des produits
etc etc
quelle fréquence vous mangez de la
viande de la viande rouge etc bon les
tout le domaine de l'équipement du
ménage hors automobile on a traité
l'automobile à part donc tout ce qui
concerne l'équipement du ménage et
l'habillement tout ce qui concerne les
habitudes domestiques en matière de
chauffage d'énergie de traitement des
déchets notamment et puis un gros un
gros poste qui est très
qui crée beaucoup de variances dans la
population qui sont les habitudes de
déplacement et l'équipement automobile
alors on a réalisé sur l'ensemble de ces
variables
des opérations statistiques qui sont
assez routinières quoi cassé complexe et
je vais pas rentrer dans le détail mais
on a pratiqué ce qu'on appelle de
l'analyse factorielle de correspondance
qui consiste pour aller très très vite
quand on a une population décrite par un
très grand nombre de variables c'est le
cas ici on a on a plus d'une vingtaine
de variables qui décrivent les individus
et au fond on essaie
algébriquement de
de de
repérer les les facteurs synthétiques
qui créent le plus de différenciation
entre les les individus des variables
qui sont
qui vont ensemble par exemple je dis je
prends un exemple un peu au hasard
faire beaucoup de kilomètres en voiture
et avoir une voiture de gros cylindrée
généralement c'est quelque chose qui est
assez corrélé bon donc
l'idée c'est de c'est vraiment de
regarder quels sont les systèmes
d'associations entre les différentes
entre les différentes habitudes et cette
analyse elle nous a elle révèle je
dirais trois principaux axes de
différenciation
des styles de vie un premier axe qui que
j'appellerai l'axe de la frugalité c'est
à dire qu'il différencie très banalement
les individus selon en fait leur volume
de de consommation et de dépenses
énergétiques
un deuxième axe qu'on était un peu
surpris de trouver en deuxième en fait
ça veut dire qu'il fait c'est le
deuxième axe de différenciation après le
volume de consommation et de dépenses
notamment énergétique c'est l'axe de
l'orientation environnementale
c'est-à-dire le degré auquel les
individus adoptent des pratiques éco
orientées alors c'est tout ce qui va
concerner le tri des le tri des déchets
l'attention
à l'origine et à la nature des produits
alimentaires
consommés par exemple et puis un
troisième axe qui fera écho à la
préoccupation territoriale que vous avez
évoqué dans votre introduction c'est un
axe de l'ancrage local de la
consommation et du style de vie qui
oppose effectivement les les styles de
vie qui sont plutôt localement ancrés et
ceux qui sont plutôt on les a qualifiés
de de cosmopolite alors j'entre pas dans
le détail mais ces analyses factorielles
ça donne lieu à des représentations
graphiques qui permettent de visualiser
un petit peu comment les les choses
s'associent quand on a des signes plus
plus là ça ça ça désigne les modalités
positives des différentes variables et
quand on a des signes moins ça ça
désigne les modalités négatives donc on
retrouve bien ici sur ce premier axe une
espèce d'opposition entre la frugalité à
droite et la et la prodigalité à gauche
vous avez à gauche des individus qui qui
roulent dans des voitures récentes qui
ont plusieurs véhicules qui achètent pas
mal de vêtements qui ont beaucoup
d'équipements électroménagers etc qui
font pas tellement attention à la
modulation de leur chauffage et puis
vous avez à droite des individus qui ont
qui ont peu d'équipement peu de voiture
etc bon on remarquera quand même que
l'axe de la frugalité il est pas il est
pas incompatible avec
avec comme on le voit en haut à à gauche
il est pas il est pas incompatible avec
un souci affirmé pour le tri des déchets
ce qui est relativement logique c'est
plus on consomme plus on produit de
déchets et donc plus on a l'occasion de
les trier ce qui veut dire que le tri
des déchets d'une certaine façon et pas
un très bon indicateur de l'orientation
écologique des des comportements de de
ce point de vue là le deuxième axe
l'orientation environnementale des
pratiques il oppose effectivement les
les les individus qui manifestent
qui manifeste une certaine
conscience environnementale dans leur
pratique de consommation de style de vie
donc des gens qui vont on le voit viande
moins moins donc des gens qui vont
consommer peu de viande qui vont être
très attentifs aux critères de de
l'origine des aliments notamment de de
critères bio qui vont plutôt avoir des
voitures anciennes
qui vont pas mal moduler leur chauffage
etc et puis de l'autre côté on va
trouver au contraire des individus qui
par exemple pas une attention
particulière aux critères bio dans
l'alimentation je vais très vite parce
que on pourrait dire beaucoup de choses
sur ces schémas mais on manque un peu de
temps puis un troisième axe qui nous a
beaucoup intéressé parce que je crois
encore que ça c'est un clivage qui est
très important dans un pays comme la
France ou le
la contradiction entre les territoires
urbains et les territoires ruraux et
peut-être plus forte que dans d'autres
sociétés européennes en tout cas c'est
cette contradiction locale globale
c'est-à-dire des styles de vie qui sont
qui sont très ancrées dans le territoire
alors qu'ils vont être qui vont être
liés au fait d'être d'une forte
dépendance à l'automobile un fort
équipement aussi
électroménager mais qui peut être lié à
des formes d'autoconsommation
c'est-à-dire qu'on a donc des choses
comme ça et puis de l'autre côté
de l'autre côté des
des alors c'est en fait c'est en
vertical qu'il faut le lire cet axe 3 de
donc
au sommet de cet axe on va voir des
modes de vie qui sont qui sont très
tournés vers vers l'extérieur vers les
vacances vers les vers les voyages à
longue distance ce qui est extrêmement
différenciateur sur cet axe là notamment
c'est les voyages en avion qui qui qui
contrairement à une idée parfois reçue
le le le voyage en avion reste quelque
chose qui est socialement extrêmement
différenciateur une très grande part de
la population française ne prend jamais
la vie en réalité donc
cette chose là est très différente bon
alors je passe sur les détails
statistiques et je vais conclure un
petit peu sur là-dessus comme je l'ai
dit en commençant ma présentation ce qui
nous a intéressé dans dans
ce travail c'est le degré auquel le
positionnement en termes de conscience
environnementale ce qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure avec les deux échelles
d'inquiétudes environnemental et de
rapport au progrès et le degré je dirais
de sobriété des modes de vie dans quelle
mesure ça se combine ou pas alors au
fond il y a il y a
on a alors on a dégagé de ça une
typologie qui est une typologie
empirique c'est pas une typologie a
priori c'est une typologie qui fait
suite au travail d'analyse factorielle
que des correspondances que je viens de
de de
présenter ça me font un algorithme de
classification qui met ensemble les
individus qui qui se ressemblent en
quelque sorte bon alors je n'entre pas
là non plus dans les détails
statistiques mais au fond la solution
assez optimale c'est une solution à 4
clusters quatre classes qu'on peut
décrire
comme je le fais ici à l'écran on a un
premier cluster
qui est très cohérent d'une certaine
façon c'est un cluster d'individu qui
est à la fois se manifeste par une
une très faible sobriété de leur mode de
vie et une très faible confiance
environnementale c'est ce que j'ai
appelé le consumérisme assumé c'est des
ménages dans lesquels il y a il y a
plusieurs véhicules il y a pas
d'attention particulière à la provenance
des produits consommés il y a beaucoup
de dépenses de consommation il y a
beaucoup de dépenses
énergétiques alors le ménage qui sont
plutôt déménagées qui ont plutôt
déménagé
urbains ou périurbains c'est plutôt des
ça peut être aussi à l'habitat
pavillonnaire mais de la bêta
pavillonnaire plutôt plutôt élevé donc
c'est ce que j'ai ce qu'on a appelé le
consumérisme il y a un deuxième cluster
qui est un des deux clusters un peu
contradictoires c'est ce qu'on a appelé
l'écho consumérisme
c'est c'est un cluster qui est composé
d'individus qui manifeste une assez
forte conscience environnementale qui se
manifeste notamment par une attention
non négligeable
ou à la provenance des produits au type
d'alimentation au tri des déchets à des
choses comme ça mais ce sont quand même
des ménages qui consomment beaucoup qui
ont des niveaux de dépenses assez élevés
c'est ce qu'on a appelé les écho
consuméristes ils sont consommateurs
mais avec quand même un peu de un peu de
soucis environnemental dans leur dans
leur pratique
il y a un troisième cluster qui est
d'une certaine façon quand on quand on a
quand on a commencé à faire l'analyse
avec mes collègues on s'est dit bah ça
c'est nous quoi c'est l'écho
cosmopolitisme c'est à dire ce sont des
ce sont des des
plutôt des urbains diplômés
assez préoccupé par les questions
environnementales dans leur pratique et
dans leurs attitudes mais qui ruine en
quelque sorte tous leurs efforts en
prenant l'avion assez souvent pour le
dire assez vite c'est pour ça qu'on les
a appelés écho cosmopolite parce qu'on
fonce ce sont effectivement
des catégories alors qu'ils sont pas
très nombreuses mais qui qui sont assez
présentes dans les élites sociales
culturels économiques de notre société
qui sont peut-être les plus perméables
ou discours écho environnemental mais
qui sont traversés par des
contradictions importantes dans leur
mode de vie notamment du fait de leur
ouverture sur l'extérieur les voyages
etc
et puis enfin un dernier classeur qui
est assez nombreux et qui je pense est
quand même politiquement très important
c'est ce qu'on a appelé la frugalité
sans intention ce sont en fait des
ménages dont le mode de vie est marqué
par une très forte obriété mais qui
était essentiellement une sobriété
contrainte il se briété sous contrainte
de budget notamment
mais qui manifeste pas particulièrement
de de conscience de de conscience
environnementale et lorsque cluster est
important parce que je pense que c'est
un des intérêts de cette classification
c'est que je pense que ça doit nous
amener à réfléchir à la manière dont on
oriente notamment un certain nombre de
de
campagne de sensibilisation aux
questions environnementales etc bon par
rapport au ménage qui sont dans cette
dernière catégorie ce que ce qu'on a
appelé la frugalité de son intention une
certaine façon tout le discours orienté
vers la sensibilisation grands enjeux
il a en réalité pas grand intérêt parce
que au fond ce sont des ménages qui sont
déjà dans la dans la sobriété du d'une
certaine façon et qui sont pas
véritablement concernés par les enjeux
de de de de prise de conscience ce qui
peut concerner ces ménages là c'est
plutôt tout ce qui va concerner les
infrastructures notamment de transport
parce que c'est aussi dans ces dans ces
ménages là qu'on va trouver malgré tout
les catégories qui sont les plus piégées
dans le périurbain notamment par l'usage
de l'automobile etc bon alors pour
terminer tout à fait et pour revenir un
petit peu au
questionnement politique on a un peu
regardé aussi comment se comment se
distribuer ces quatre profils
dans en termes de d'auto positionnement
politique alors bon il y a des
constats assez assez triviaux
globalement si on regarde tout tout à
fait
à droite on voit qu'il y a une forme
quand même de gradient
une forme de gradient droit de gauche
dans ces questions mais qui n'est pas si
évident que ça c'est-à-dire que bon
alors on voit bien que le consumérisme
assumait on le trouve quand même moins à
gauche qu'ailleurs
la frugalité sans intention
elle est pas très facile à caractériser
politiquement sans doute parce qu'on est
aussi dans des populations qui ce qui
nourrissent beaucoup les rangs de
l'abstention
électorale l'écho cosmopolitisme c'est
pas très surprenant il est plutôt marqué
à gauche ce qu'on a on a presque 50% des
gens qui se trouve à qui s'auto
positionne à gauche enfin 47% qui se
positionne à gauche ou à l'extrême
gauche ce qui est ce qui nous a
intéressé c'est le positionnement de ce
cluster qu'on a appelé Eco consumérisme
parce que ce qui le caractérise c'est à
la fois
une assez forte présence à gauche mais
une assez forte présence aussi à
l'extrême droite c'est là qu'on trouve
une certaine sur-reprétation 21% de
d'auto positionnement à l'extrême droite
qu'on retrouve pas dans dans les autres
clusters tout ça nous a amené à conclure
et je pense que c'est une question
politiquement importante pour l'avenir
au fond
l'écologie politique en termes d'offres
politiques spécifiques existent et
existera sans doute dans l'avenir mais
ce qui caractérise sans doute l'époque
c'est que nous entrons peut-être dans
une période d'où la préoccupation
environnementale elle est présente sur
l'ensemble dans l'ensemble du spectre
politique où elle fait l'objet de de
réponse politique différente qui qui
appuie sur des leviers qui sont pas les
mêmes certains vont privilégier le
progrès technique d'autres vont
privilégier dans une logique de marché
l'efficacité des mécanismes de signal
prix d'autres enfin vont
privilégier les mécanismes de
planification etc bon et il nous a
semblé qu'effectivement la
différenciation sociale et politique des
attitudes et des pratiques va refléter
un petit peu peut-être aussi le fait de
que nous entrons peut-être dans cette
période où au fond la la question
environnementale s'invite dans le débat
social et politique
et que sans doute une partie du débat
social et politique est appelé à
s'organiser autour de de la diversité de
la conflictualité des réponses
apportées à ces questions
environnementales je vous remercie de
votre attention
merci beaucoup ce que l'on joue pour
cette présentation particulièrement
intéressante et riche avant de laisser
la parole à mes collègues pour vous
poser quelques questions j'ai moi-même
une interrogation à l'homme de votre
présentation alors peut-être
que pour répondre à ma deuxième question
vous allez m'indiquer qu'il aurait fallu
une nouvelle enquête ce que vous avez
préalablement indiqué le premier sujet
c'est par rapport à la typologie que
vous avez réalisé à l'exception on va
dire de de l'éco-consumériste
je veux dire les trois autres typologies
ne sont guère encourageantes en ceux qui
entre ceux qui voudraient mais qui ne
peuvent pas et entre ceux qui ne peuvent
pas et qui auraient une conscience
quelque part
écologique
ceci mise à part et ça m'amène vraiment
à la question centrale que je voulais
vous poser
ce qui fait qu'on va peut-être changer
de paradigme mais et que le prisme est
différent c'est que pour beaucoup quand
même de nos concitoyens et on le voit
perception et Gale réalité mais
peut-être que aujourd'hui la réalité
s'impose et notamment au regard de de
crises que nous venons pour l'une de
connaître qui est la crise
de l'énergie qui réinterroge quelque
part nos certitudes on imaginait pas
parler délestage et encore ne serait-ce
que 4-5 ans et celle j'ai évoqué le
rapport que nous venons de commettre on
voit les travaux qui se multiplient dans
nos dans nos assemblées et le thème de
l'eau qui revient sur le devant de la
scène suite à l'épisode de sécheresse
que nous venons de connaître et celui
qui se profile à l'horizon et c'est deux
crises finalement réinterrogent comme je
le disais non
nos certitudes et quelque part nous
oblige parce qu'elles nous nous renvoie
des besoins qui sont des besoins
primaires
et singulièrement s'agissant de l'eau
entre
le fait de pouvoir
s'alimenter par rapport à ce qu'on va
produire sur le plan de l'agriculture et
boire tout simplement
et nous renvoie aussi à des conflits qui
ceux qui se profilent parce que on voit
bien on a essayé de traiter le sujet
notamment sur le la question du stockage
de l'eau qui devient consubstantiel pour
pouvoir soutenir quelques certaines
formes d'agriculture de façon assez
générale l'agriculture avec les épisodes
de de sécheresse et le débat
environnemental sous-jacent et puis le
fait effectivement d'utiliser l'eau pour
pour boire à l'heure où on a des
communes qui sont privés tout simplement
dos robinet qui doivent faire l'objet
d'un soutien par d'autres collectivités
pour acheminer de l'eau moi je suis dans
un département le préfet vient de
prendre une décision d'interdire dans 26
communes la délivrance de permis de
construire dès lors qu'on a pas réaliser
certains travaux notamment pour aller
capter l'eau dans la nappe du Rhône
enfin bon autant de sujets qui voilà
sont d'une part inquiétant d'autre part
réinterroge des comme je le disais des
des certitudes et qui nécessairement
alors là pour le coup qu'on est une
qu'on soit comme une conscience dans sa
consommation qu'on ne l'est pas voilà on
est au pied du mur si j'ose dire et
c'est phénomènes vont nous obliger vont
nous obliger aussi à changer nos modes
de pratique et nos modes de de
consommation et donc est-ce que vous
pensez que ces événements là sont de
nature je reste sur votre typologie et
faire évoluer cette typologie évoluer la
répartition alors politique mais pas que
que vous venez nous nous présenter
oui alors c'est facile c'est difficile
d'anticiper ce que ce que donnerait les
résultats d'une enquête qui a pas été
faite mais qui je suis de plus en plus
convaincu qu'il faut effectivement qu'on
refasse assez rapidement cette enquête
ce qui est pas techniquement très
compliqué il faut juste qu'on trouve les
20000 euros qui qui sont nécessaires
pour la financer mais c'est pas pas une
somme colossale je pense parce
qu'effectivement entre 2017 et
aujourd'hui il s'est passé beaucoup de
choses il s'est passé notamment beaucoup
de choses ces derniers mois beaucoup de
choses qui à mon avis mettent en
évidence deux éléments qui sont
sous-jacents dans votre propos
la première chose je reviens à cette
histoire de conflictualité au fond
longtemps les questions en caricaturant
je dirais que mon temps les questions
environnementales ont été envisagées de
manière un peu fleur bleue c'est-à-dire
de quelque chose d'un peu consensuel on
est tous on est tous d'accord sur le
fait qu'il faut protéger la nature etc
on voit bien et alors on l'a vu
effectivement de manière
particulièrement spectaculaire ces
derniers jours mais on voit à plein
d'occasions que les questions qui sont
qui sont en cause notamment la question
de l'eau qui commence à apparaître
peuvent être l'objet de de conflits qui
sont effectivement très importants donc
c'est une question qui qui devient
conflictuel dans ce sont des questions
qui deviennent conflictuels dans dans la
société je veux dire la conflictualité
autour de questions environnementales
elle a longtemps été limitée à l'aspect
j'allais dire anecdotique il est quand
même pas anecdotique dans tous les
territoires mais un anecdotique au sens
au sens de la France en entier de la
question des rapports entre les
défenseurs de l'environnement et les
chasseurs par exemple encore une fois
dans certains territoires c'est pas du
tout anecdotique c'est très structurant
politiquement mais bon il y a pas de ce
conflit là effectivement on voit bien
que toutes ces questions là vont devenir
très conflictuelles et la deuxième chose
et ça je pense que malheureusement notre
outil est pas adapté pour ça parce que
il repose sur un échantillon
France entière alors qu'il faudrait des
enquêtes à mon avis beaucoup plus
localisées et je pense qu'il y a une
forte différenciation et de la
conscience et des pratiques selon les
territoires
les questions environnementales
aujourd'hui apparaissent très
différemment à nos concitoyens selon le
selon leur cadre de vie et bon vous vous
allez dans les zones montagnes par
exemple aujourd'hui
les les gens vivent concrètement depuis
plusieurs années effectivement ce que
c'est que le réchauffement climatique
des sports d'hiver etc qui qui va
disparaître dans plein de territoires
vers ceux qui vivent de ça ils ont
compris qu'ils étaient que c'était fini
bon dans certains territoires
ou l'agriculture est très très
consommatrice d'eau les gens ont compris
qu'il y avait
il peut y avoir encore une certaine
forme je dirais de une certaine forme
d'insouciance dans d'autres parties dans
d'autres parties du territoire donc
cette question des des
territorial elle me paraît extrêmement
importante oui vous
non alors moi il est difficile de
préjugé ce que ce que ce que ce que
donnerait cette typologie si on si on
reproduisait l'enquête aujourd'hui
est-ce que ma typologie elle est
optimiste ou pessimiste alors moi je
suis assez agnostique là-dessus mais
enfin en tout cas je vous je vous
livrerai pas le fond de mon âme en tout
cas pas ici mais mais
disons que disons que je pense que
encore une fois l'intérêt de cette
typologie c'est c'est de montrer je
crois qu'il faut différencier les
leviers c'est à dire que
il est évident que tout ce qui est tout
ce qui peut relever des outils de la
contrainte ça risque de concerner plus
ceux que j'ai appelé les conflits assumé
que les autres bon je je je pense qu'il
faut sans doute politiquement se
préparer au fait que certaines
catégories de ménage vont être obligés
de peut-être restreindre un certain
nombre d'éléments de leur train de vie
bon aujourd'hui ça paraît ça paraît
liberticide mais peut-être que dans
quelques années ça paraîtra
complètement complètement inévitable bon
alors voilà la question est-ce que tu
sais est-ce que cette typologie est
optimiste ou pessimiste je poserai la
question un peu différemment c'est à
dire que cette typologie elle appelle
effectivement des décisions politiques
elle appelle des choix politiques qui
sont qui sont peut-être pas facile c'est
plutôt comme ça que je trouvais envie de
vous le dire à vous
excusez-moi c'était juste pour
m'inscrire dans la suite du débat merci
en tout cas pour pour votre présentation
qui vont d'une façon plus générale donne
à voir mais comme tout étude un certain
nombre de contradictions que je
qualifierais un peu inhérente à l'être
humain et donc à l'humanité et très
certainement qui en tout cas nous pousse
à agir voilà la volonté de pouvoir la
dépasser les dépasserons toutes et tous
ça l'avenir le dira moi j'avais une
question quand j'avais plusieurs
questions bon une vous y avez
partiellement répondu vous avez
effectivement défini quatre clusters
compris avec un parallélisme de ensuite
où les gens se positionnent
dans un découpage politique qui
d'ailleurs est-il encore révélateur
première interrogation mais voilà qui
est en tout cas un repère dans notre
pays est-ce que vous avez par les
éléments de cette étude des capacités à
affiner découpage de cluster plus par
catégorie sociale plus par effectivement
mais bon vous nous dites que ça
mériterait approfondissement je dirais
par catégorie territoriale
coeur de grande ville
périurbain territoire ruraux et est-ce
qu'il y a des croisements où là encore
un certain nombre d'oppositions pour
donner à voir finalement une image de la
diversité aussi de ses propres
contradictions
on évoquait et notre président le
rappelait les deux crises que récentes
que sont celles de l'énergie et de l'eau
je rajouterai tout de même également
donc depuis votre étude qui date de 2017
c'est ça si je me suis pas trompé voilà
de 2017 à 2023 nous avons aussi vécu une
grande crise mondiale qui a été la
pandémie ou
et je relisais ce week-end quoi le
dernier livre de Jean Viard je regarde
qui donne à voir comment des milliards
d'individus ont été confinés tous en
même temps
et si de cette pandémie un nouveau
moteur voilà collectif naissait aussi
prenant conscience d'un certain nombre
de réalité liées aux enjeux climatiques
de demain et puis plus particulièrement
pour nous le retour également de la
guerre sur le sol européen qui doit qui
je pense alors j'entends les contraintes
financières mais nécessiterait
inévitablement à donner à voir en quoi
cela bouleverse aussi le rapport aux
enjeux aux enjeux environnementaux vous
avez parlé d'inquiétude écologique
et je finirai sur sur ce point là
est-ce qu'il alors est-ce que les gens
expriment une inquiétude ou est-ce qu'on
les conditionne à ressentir une
inquiétude écologique
est-ce que
c'est inquiétude peut devenir telle une
peur panique un acteur de l'immobilisme
qui inciterait à finalement une forme de
repli à préserver ce qu'on a
d'aller vers un avenir encore plus
incertain au regard de ces crises
alors nous ne vous demanderons pas de
dévoiler le fond de votre âme vous
n'êtes vous êtes un chercheur nous
sommes des parlementaires mais est-ce
que finalement l'enjeu du politique
demain mais dès aujourd'hui n'est pas de
cette capacité à transformer ce qui peut
être une inquiétude légitime ressentie
comme tel en un vecteur qui deviendrait
plus positif et qui effectivement
viseraient à faire agir chacune et
chacun sans être un facteur là encore
d'exclusion je vous avais voté l'action
de la voiture je vais prendre cet
exemple là déclarer qu'il ne faut plus
de voitures diesel
pour des enjeux environnementaux
l'adaptabilité est beaucoup plus facile
dans les milieux aisés ou on peut demain
changer de modèle de voiture passé à une
voiture électrique et finalement
ne rien impacter ou si peu en tout cas
dans ces modes de vie du quotidien par
rapport à d'autres catégories sociales
qui elles doivent demain repenser toute
leur mobilité tout leur budget mensuel
annuel du ménage et donc je
comment est-ce que vous vous sentez dans
cette société dans ces études avec des
des angles d'approche peut-être
différentes que la simple catégorie
classe sociale qui fut celle de
l'analyse de la société française
pendant des décennies pour permettre que
justement la crise de l'eau par exemple
demain ne nous oppose pas mais nous
rassemble dans la capacité à gérer ce
bien de toute indispensable à on voit
aujourd'hui alors pour plein de facteurs
qui d'ailleurs ne sont pas écologiques
qui sont des fois la lenteur de
l'instruction de l'État qui sont une
forme de radicalité de d'une partie de
la société un film qui qui cherche
l'affrontement mais comment est-ce que
demain c'est gestion de crise deviennent
des facteurs positif dans nos sociétés
qui visent plutôt à nous rassembler
plutôt qu'à nous qu'à nous opposer parce
que il me semble mais là c'est peut-être
un jugement très politique que je ferais
que une société où l'on s'affronte une
société qui peut être demain le fruit
d'émeute et on le voit dans d'autres
pays de guerre quelle qu'elle soit n'est
pas non plus bon pour la préservation
environnementale et donc n'est pas non
plus bon pour pour les défis climatiques
et écologiques que nous aurons en relevé
collectivement et je m'excuse parce
qu'après votre réponse je devrais
m'absenter j'ai une autre réunion par
ailleurs voilà excusez-moi alors je sais
pas si je vais réussir à répondre à
toutes vos questions parce qu'il y en
avait beaucoup je vais essayer de
répondre à quelques-unes sur la la les
caractéristiques sociales de ces
différents de ces différents clusters
alors
alors deux choses
bon c'est encore une fois cette
typologie c'est une typologie empirique
on l'a pas on l'a pas imposé à priori
c'est vraiment ce qui ressort des des
associations entre les les variables qui
sont renseignées dans l'enquête alors
on pourrait l'affiner cette typologie
c'est-à-dire qu'à l'intérieur des
différents types on pourrait
dégager des sous-titres etc bon on le
fera peut-être d'ailleurs mais bon dans
dans un bon temps mais bon
pour ce qui est de la différenciation
sociale de oui alors je l'ai pas montré
parce que je voulais limiter le nombre
de d'éléments projetés ce matin mais
tout ça c'est présent dans le dans le
livre
c'est c'est
différent profils sont très caractérisés
socialement c'est à dire que bon alors
avec la caractéristique qui pour
certaines sont pas très surprenantes
c'est-à-dire que le cluster de du
consumérisme assumé on trouve plutôt
dans dans les catégories
à niveau de rémunération élevé plutôt
chez plutôt chez les 4 supérieures et
aussi un peu chez les indépendants quand
même
tandis que le le la frugalité la
frugalité sans intention elle est très
caractéristique des des classes
populaires des des c'est là aussi qu'on
ait la plus forte sur représentation des
chômeurs dans dans ce cluster dans ce
cluster là donc il y a un certain nombre
effectivement de facteurs sociaux qui
sont très différenciés les les éléments
les peut-être les plus intéressants sont
sur le ce qu'on a appelé l'écho
consumérisme parce que ça c'est très
caractéristique quand même des ménages
retraités c'est-à-dire des gens qui ont
qui ont finalement le qui qui ont pas
mal de temps à consacrer c'est une
hypothèse qu'on fait aux
pratiques vertueuses qui sont qui qui
nécessitent du temps à les comparer les
les produits les choses etc prendre le
temps de faire la cuisine plutôt que
d'acheter de l'alimentation préparée etc
bon donc ça c'est effectivement très
caractéristique de de d'ailleurs c'est
une chose qui nous a un peu frappé c'est
à dire qu'on s'attendait beaucoup à ce
qu'il y a un espèce de gradient d'âge
que plus les gens sont jeunes plus ils
sont et co orientés c'est pas si clair
que ça en fait Patrick clair que ça
parce que justement ce que cette ce ce
ce qu'on a appelé cette écho
consumérisme c'est plutôt
caractéristique de de ménage qui
appartiennent plutôt
aux générations du du baby-boom donc en
fait c'est pas si c'est fallu dire les
champions du tri c'est plutôt c'est
plutôt par exemple bon donc c'est c'est
pas le le le le le critère de l'âge j'ai
pas de fille et pas si clair bon et de
la même façon ce qu'on a appelé les
échos cosmopolite c'est très clairement
des ménages de de capsule plutôt
diplômés quoi enfin
ce qu'on appelle vulgairement les bobos
bon voilà donc voilà
comme je vous disais tout à l'heure
quand on faisait la typologie on se dit
bah ça c'est nous voilà
le mois
en plaisantant à moitié bon
à moitié parce que pour
répondre un peu à votre question finale
sur est-ce que tout ça ça nous prépare
du conflit ou est-ce que ça nous prépare
du du constaté moi je crois que ça que
que alors là je vais peut-être
m'engager un peu sur sur une voie un peu
pessimiste là pour le coup je pense
qu'il y a devant nous effectivement des
choses assez conflictuelles les
conflictuelles vont pas forcément dire
émeutes et guerre civile le conflit au
sens le conflit régulé et pacifié c'est
aussi le c'est aussi l'essence de la vie
politique à charge pour les politiques
justement d'inventer les forces de
régulation du conflit mais je crois
effectivement que les questions qui sont
devant nous sont des questions qui qui
seront pas consensuelles soit parce
qu'elles imposeront des contraintes
non négligeable sur les modes de vie des
plus aisés de nos concitoyens soit parce
que elles imposeront des choix en
matière de financement d'infrastructures
qui auront des incidents fiscales qui
auront des incidences en termes de
redistribution etc qui seront pas
indolores non plus bon voilà donc je
pense que ces questions là
oui c'est que c'est quand même un peu la
conclusion du livre on est vraiment au
cœur d'une question politique avec un
grand P et le
je pense quand même que une des
enseignements qu'on a ressortis de ce
livre c'est que je pense qu'il faut il
faut il est peut-être temps de sortir
d'une vision un peu consensuelle et
naïve de de des questions
environnementales malheureusement c'est
des questions qui vont nous opposer mais
encore une fois voilà c'est la c'est
c'est la vie de la cité
justement il est temps de faire la
deuxième enquête pour voir un peu
et puis voir si
le vieillissement de la population qu'on
constate comme dans tous les pays
européens
en tenir compte par comment j'avais une
question plus
précise c'était sur les quatre classes
quel est le pourcentage respectif est-ce
qu'il y en a une qui prédomine ou c'est
là effectivement il faut que je regarde
partout
j'ai pu les chiffres en tête là je dois
l'avoir que je dois l'avoir je dois
l'avoir quelque part
je l'ai forcément quelque part
il me semble que c'est des que c'est des
proportions relativement
relativement similaire attendez je vais
je vais vous retrouver ça tout de suite
non non non mais c'est que en fait je
peux voilà je suis parti sur d'autres
choses c'est
alors en fait
premier le consumérisme assumé 28%
éco-consumérisme 28 et demi donc c'est à
peu près pareil et cocosmopolitisme 16
et demi et puis la frugalité sans
intention 27% donc en gros c'est
l'écocosmopolitisme qui est plus qui est
plus minoritaire parce que ça représente
lui pèse
culturellement et socialement privilégié
on va dire voilà mais les autres
représentent à peu près le le même poids
oui oui effectivement oui alors ça donne
effectivement une image quand même assez
clivée oui effectivement oui mais ça
correspond à quand on voit les
géographes etc ça correspond tout à fait
et justement par rapport à ça est-ce que
dans un bon tempo quand on parlait de de
mobilité d'aller vers tout le téléthique
où on voit bien les difficultés que
c'est important parce que ça dépendra
des moyens est-ce que justement on n'est
pas suffisamment raisonnable souvent
pour pas mettre tous nos œufs dans le
même panier est-ce qu'on ne devrait pas
mettre en tout cas être raisonnable et
pas mettre tous nos œufs dans le même
panier faire en sorte qu'on accompagne
ces gens qui sont au diesel on peut les
associer pour de biocarburant en
attendant progressivement
la transition elle peut pas se faire le
but en blanc quoi alors donc il faut
faire attention à ça attention dans les
énergies notamment parce que regardez
les éoliennes ils vont aller chez qui
qui va consommer ça va être l'urbain et
l'éolienne qui va se la taper ça va être
le rural voyez-vous et on va bouleverser
comme ça des équilibres paysagers ou
autres et derrière ça fait des prises de
conscience de la dimension écologique
qui deviennent des gens que vous mettez
à dos plutôt que de vous les associez
parce que parce que il y a un certain
nombre d'inconvénients est-ce que
justement dans la politique qu'on doit
mener on doit pas prendre en compte ces
facteurs pour essayer de façon graduelle
et répartie que chacun participe à
l'effort collectif et on voit bien les
difficultés quand on demande un effort
collectif en France on vient de le voir
avec les retraites que c'est pas facile
à faire admettre et là on sera peut-être
dans la même logique non oui alors je
pense qu'effectivement la diversité des
profils qui ressort de cette enquête je
dirais à minima parce que c'est pas mon
rôle que de de de de faire des
propositions politiques mais mais mais
la diversité des profils d'attitude et
de styles de vie
résonne quand même un peu comme un appel
à la diversification des leviers
d'actions et des outils à qu'on peut
vraisemblablement pas appliquer les
mêmes outils à toutes les populations je
prends juste un exemple le mécanisme du
signal prix qui est fortement défendu
par un certain nombre d'économistes avec
des arguments qui sont tout à fait
solides on voit bien qu'il y a quand
même toute une partie de la population
qui est quand même un peu à la marge de
la société de consommation pour lequel
le signal prix va pas avoir en intérêt
en revanche effectivement les catégories
les plus
les moins contraintes dans leurs
dépenses le mécanisme signal pris s'il
est un peu sévère
il peut avoir une certaine efficacité
donc voilà l'exemple du signal prix me
semble être de tous les mécanismes
carbone et autres me laisse à penser
effectivement que ces mécanismes ces
outils là ils peuvent être adaptés à
certaines populations mais pas à
d'autres et on l'a bien vu quand on a
essayé
de manière sans doute un peu trop
improvisée d'introduire une taxe carbone
en France on a bien vu ce que ça ce que
ça a suscité
avec le risque effectivement qu'on est
enterré cette idée pour pour des années
alors que inévitablement je pense qu'il
faudra sans doute y revenir mais bon
voilà
peut-être en ayant effectivement
conscience de forme de modulation selon
les populations bien sûr
moi j'avais une dernière question
déplacer un peu le débat sur l'angle
sous l'angle
philosophique peut-être plus que
politique mais est-ce que au fond la
solution elle n'est pas générationnelle
en ce sens que et d'ailleurs est-ce que
vous avez
dans votre étude
regardez au niveau des typologies et des
segments d'âge
on voit bien mais pour des raisons qui
sont absolument évidentes parliez du tri
sélectif de de l'approche et du rapport
justement à la consommation on voit bien
que
à chaque génération sa propre vérité sa
propre approche sur tous ces sujets
environnementaux et sur les pratiques
qui en découlent
est-ce qu'au fond il y a pas une
adaptation qui est beaucoup plus facile
beaucoup plus aisée y compris dans la
compréhension chez les générations un
peu un peu plus jeunes entre guillemets
qui ont grandi ou qui grandissent
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui confronté qu'ils
sont
assez réalités et c'est pratique qui
sont peut-être eux leurs prises et le
postulat de départ mais en tout cas dans
lequel il évoluent aujourd'hui oui alors
c'est toujours très compliqué de de
mesurer ces phénomènes générationnels
alors j'entre pas dans le là non plus
dans le dans le détail technique de la
statistique mais pour vraiment mesurer
des évolutions de génération il faut
disposer de série d'enquêtes pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir distinguer ce qui
relève des effets d'âge va des effets de
cycle de vie de des effets de génération
proprement dit ce qui semble apparaître
quand même mais ça serait à confirmer
c'est un argument supplémentaire pour
répliquer l'enquête ce qui semble
apparaître quand même c'est qu'il y a il
y a deux générations qui ont des
spécificités fortes il y a quand même la
génération je dirais de les générations
de la prière les générations qui qui ont
grandi je dirais dans la consommation de
masse pour lesquelles il y a sans doute
une l'impression qu'un peu plus
compliqué parce qu'au fond il y a une
espèce de ce qui est compréhensible une
espèce de fascination pour pour progrès
technique pour la consommation les bons
voilà le le le le le l'électroménager
gros et petit enfin bon tout tout tout
c'est facilités de de de la vie moderne
et puis il y a les générations montantes
qui seront peut-être qui sont peut-être
prises aussi dans alors on les trouve
beaucoup dans le dans le ce que
j'appelais l'écho cosmopolitisme
d'ailleurs les les générations les plus
récentes avec des choses qui sont encore
mal mesurées mais qui vont être un enjeu
quand même c'est tout ce qui concerne le
la consommation numérique
qui a quand même un impact
environnemental non négligeable alors le
plus important est pas d'ailleurs le et
pas tant la consommation de flux alors
oui c'est un impact parce que les
serveurs tout ça ça mais c'est plutôt la
question du renouvellement accélérée des
équipements je veux dire le marché du
renouvellement du smartphone c'est quand
même une catastrophe environnementale et
ça effectivement les jeunes générations
ont des taux de renouvellement de ce
genre d'équipement qui sont quand même
un peu inquiétants bon donc oui il y a
des chaque génération en quelque sorte à
sans doute ses pratiques et ses
consommations fétiches en quelque sorte
qui appelle là aussi sans doute des
réponses spécifiques et la question de
où est la question de l'obsolescence des
des équipements
qui je pense sur la question de
l'informatique du numérique etc est une
vraie question où je pense qu'il y a une
conversion très importante à faire va
très anecdotiquement là moi je je le
vois dans mon secteur d'activité je
pense que dans le monde de la recherche
et de l'université on
consomme un peu avec légèreté de
l'ordinateur c'est-à-dire que je pense
qu'il va quand même falloir un moment
penser à former du personnel pour pour
maintenir les appareils plutôt que de
changer tous les deux ans enfin bon
c'est des choses c'est des choses toutes
bêtes mais je pense que le secteur
tertiaire le produit quand même beaucoup
de déchets liés au numérique qui va
beaucoup d'obsolescence et des
équipements qui sont très coûteux en
termes de ressources environnementales
et je pense qu'il y a vraiment des des
réflexions à mener il y a des réflexions
à mener aussi sur sur notre rapport sur
notre rapport aux autres rapports à
l'espace pour notre rapport à l'espace
et au voyage à longue distance c'est
clair que les jeunes générations ont été
plus habitués que les précédentes à la
facilité avec laquelle on se déplace à
travers le monde et je pense qu'il y a
sans doute effectivement des des choses
qui vont devoir changer là-dessus là
encore moi je suis dans un milieu où on
a longtemps été assez léger par rapport
à ces questions là et hésitant pas à
traverser la planète pour aller parler
20 minutes dans un congrès du monde
genre de truc qui c'est il y a une vraie
conversion là c'est assez marrant ça
passe plus voilà donc je termine
certaines il y a cette année le Congrès
de l'Association
internationale de sociologie qui a lieu
à Melbourne donc en Australie ceux de
nos collègues qui ont décidé d'y aller
sont regarder dans d'un seul œil par les
autres parce qu'on dit quand même est-ce
bien raisonnable d'aller jusqu'en
Australie pour aller faire une
communication de 20 minutes que vous
pourriez faire en zoom quoi bon pensez
aux gens il y a toutes ces questions là
qui sont qui sont devant nous aussi bon
très bien bah écoutez il nous reste à
vous remercier pour ces échanges
passionnants et puis surtout cet
éclairage et
manquerons pas j'ai dire de nourrir de
ses travaux pour évoquer à nouveau je
pense un sujet qui est un des fils
rouges
de nos réflexions au sein de la
délégation j'ai parlé notamment des
travaux sur l'eau on en aura beaucoup
qui vont un peu s'articuler autour du
même sujet en tout cas un grand merci de
votre présence merci à vous vous êtes
contribution merci beaucoup